[Musique]
il
ils sont
attendez
la vitalité
messi
[Musique]
moi ce qui me fait bouger sais
je sais pas je bouge beaucoup par façon
c'est les gens ça les gens c'est ce que
je fais c'est une curiosité
moi paris c'est ce que je pense et
une tranquillité je peux pas l'habitude
notre ville parce que parce que si je
suis bien c'est
tu te balades comme ça dans une rue dans
un quartier
très chaude avec des gens tu vois tu
sens tu fais actuellement
je me sens bien
j'ai pas fini envie de partir donc
dire j'ai envie de rester ici non plus
de faire des choses ici ni avec des gens
dans des lieux
[Musique]
j'ai vécu ici moi je vais diriger pas de
vécu ailleurs moi je suis venu monde
d'algérie je vais dire j'ai des attaches
j'ai vécu six mois si je connais c'est
ainsi que j'ai des amis c'est ici que
[Musique]
dire là bas je suis de la famille mais
je n'ai pas vu depuis 20 ans hier comme
on dit loin des yeux loin du coeur à
part un affectif qui demeure parce que
c'est ce que je suis pas ce qu'on me
reproche d'être comme ça en proche donc
la seule défense et de dire oui le
mettre en avant je suis content
[Musique]
oh
peut-être un jour je prendrai la
nationalité française dire ça parce que
je vis ici mais mais quand il aura pas
de problème quand j'aurai envie de la
prendre pas parce que derrière un pouce
et que je suis obligé d'un point puis
dire ça c'est une assimilation forcée
là je vis je vis oui je vis ici avec je
fais il fait tout comme comme un
français mais je reste à le gérer je
fais ont scié j'ai bossé h aux songes et
électriciens
j'ai beaucoup bossé avec les gamins je
fais beaucoup d'animation
soit dans des foyers cas sociaux parce
qu'on appelle des cas sans fil et
j'anime des ateliers va mais qui tape
qui va avec ton avis avec c'est pas la
peine bon bon bon quand tu soulignes je
suis et puis ça c'est bien c'est beau
mais si tu bouges tout le temps ça on le
voit plus on se dit bon fait tous
pareils quoi hein alors toi ton rythme
aussi le temps de repas dans c'est pas
parce que c'est soit disant fait une
caricature d'aristocrates qu'elle parle
comme ça tout comme ça et puis tout
doucement et puis à l'exil aussi
c'est une vipère
confessions sur l'oreiller elle ces
messieurs va mais elle parle pas de
pieux comme lou
hockey
et après on passe à une lecture de la
semaine
et moi ça ça m'intéresse je fais pas du
théâtre simplement pour pour en faire
dans un vase clos un peu et puis que les
gens viennent ça soit assez bien bravo
cap cup on s'en va c'est j'en fais parce
que parce que de donner des émotions qui
sont qui sont quotidiennes une banalité
qui qui n'est plus banal quoi
et tu travailles à vous tous avec des
gens sur sur des sensibilités et ça
c'est possible localement sur un petit
kart et avec avec les gens qui ont envie
compétent ou pas mais
c'est vrai démarche quoi c'est l'intérêt
celle envie c'est d'être amoureux de la
vie quoi de certaines choses
donc voilà alors là je vais j'essaie je
fais tout pour pour le faire dès que la
bk une occasion juste au dessus tel soi
même même gratuite c'est pas c'est pas
forcément lucratif c'est dans le fait de
faire c'est d'être un peu gourmand avec
heures avec les gens
[Musique]
amar'e chers amis bonjour comment allez
vous oui je vous avez vous félicite et
ce surtout mes compliments d'ailleurs
quel plaisir de retrouver tant de gens
du monde et quel honneur d'avoir reçu le
press and monte à l'envers jeune homme
charmant
et gears et vous d'ailleurs mais pour
l'instant c'est un secret puis autre
parole bien sûr et bien le prince sort
de chez moi non oui
vraiment une nuit
délicieux ma chère je suis fière puiser
comment vous ne doutez pas vous aurez le
comprendre que le prince vous a déjà
accordé ses faveurs
possibles économies n'avait rien dit
mais très cher pourquoi nous priver du
récit de vos aventures
voyez vous moi cela m'amuse de tout
raconter mon presse serait ce que pour
embêter ses devis big la duchesse de
benoît son habit de revioo les
intégristes insupportable à la salle d
orléans voyez vous nous ma chère nous
préférons la confession surveiller
dites moi n'avez-vous jamais eu vraiment
un homme du peuple oui évrier
votre décorateur m'est très cher il
n'est pas ce que j'appelle à l'ouvrier
lui c'est un artiste et bien moi depuis
trois jours avec le premier par ma salle
de bain l'animal comme agent noir ils
tremblent espère passer
cependant j'avoue qu'il est bien monté
vraiment ça me plaît de l'impressionner
le pauvre cède à tous les caprices dans
nos repas tu t'endors là un moment comme
ça tu t'en sors tu nous racontes que la
nuque tapas et au plus avec à mac os
c'était passionnant tu vois tu es plus
lisez été
au niveau comédiens parce qu'on te
proposent quant à une tête d'arabe je
dis pas un noir en plus les problèmes
qui doivent
proposer des rôles de [ __ ] ou le
mec au ballet ou bien le jeune qui tu
vois quel délinquant à la goutte d'or ou
ailleurs
ça c'est je veux dire pour pour moi je
veux dire bon moi je suis comédien je
suis avant tout à l'individu et dans la
vie de tous les jours tu vois bon j'ai
pas le même problème que mes parents
passent pas bien faire ce brave homme il
est venu
il est venu ici pour travailler
cergy manicouagan doral
chéchia sur la tête il parle pas un mot
de français
bon il a tout le temps il est où le
temps restait dans des ghettos dans des
endroits qu'avec des des gens de soi du
village soit soit du pays soit des
choses comme ça à dire que moi je suis
passé différent je t'aime je sais parler
français donc déjà je peux me battre
verbalement je peux me bagarrer avec la
vie avec les gens il n'ya pas longtemps
il m'est arrivé un petit truc tu vois je
devais jouer j'étais au troquet en bas
de chez moi
prenez un café comme ça pour vous pour
passer le temps et puis il y avait une
discussion à côté de moi de mai qui
discutent et puis ça commence les
[ __ ] les noirs chauffeur de bus
ils étaient loi alors ils ont commencé
sur lui alors dans le bus il y avait des
maghrébins calé à la mosquée donc il
était avec la chéchia et où ils ont
commencé bien sûr sur noah sur les
arabes
des vertes et des pas mûres
ensuite il y avait il ya une cité de
transit qui avait brûlé palau 1 et enfin
palois banlieue et le mec disait c'est
bien fait c'est bien fait a vu ça a
brûlé
lyon n'a qu' il y en a que trois ou
quatre qui sont qui sont décédés il en
réchappe toujours j'ai commencé le café
de travers je l'avalé puis je suis
intervenu commencé à dire les [ __ ]
moi c'était plus fort que moi je pouvais
plus considérer avant tout qu'est-ce que
je suis un [ __ ] mer dont je veux
dire je vais pas peindre des cheveux en
blond babyliss et compagnie
[Musique]
là
mais qui
mais le groupe et le coq
pour les décisions
[Musique]
montreux il ya des gens peut-être que ça
va choquer jédir bout voilà c'est ce que
je peux pas je ne peux pas le changement
faire comme dans pae chocolat à
atteindre non parce que je me mettrai
aussi peut-être dans une glace
[Musique]